all right nicole
yes nicole where'd you go where are you
from originally um i grew up in
lancaster california and i'm originally
from lancaster
um
i moved to la when i was 13.
tell me about your family you had both
your parents
um no i have my mom but not my dad
where was dad
a prison
yeah he'd been in prison my whole life
um well he hasn't really been in prison
my whole life but
you know he's been like in and out so
basically
how would you describe your childhood in
general
chaotic
what kind of stuff is going on
a lot um i was
i was
sexually assaulted when i was younger
so yeah that way how young like i was 10
i was 10 and 12. so it happened twice
and um
i guess yeah that's really what made my
lifestyle the way it is because
you know my mom didn't believe me at
some point you know so that kind of took
a toll on my life
you feel like that changed the direction
yeah definitely because you know i felt
you know neglected in a way
so i left home and then i was in foster
foster homes after that because i ran
away yeah so i've been in foster homes
since i was 13 all the way to until i
was 18.
i was i've been in the system since then
yeah
and you stopped at school at what point
i graduated you did mm-hmm
in a different state though not here
through the like the through the system
yeah yeah
and how did you get introduced to sex
work
um
i had a girlfriend
and she did it but i'm she been she was
doing it before me
but you know she kind of like she threw
an image like you know towards me you
know i don't know it was like an image i
liked you know
so
yeah what age was that when you started
15 and a half
and you've been working fig since then i
started on fig yes
but i always i haven't been like
consistently working you know i it been
like oh you know i'll do it and then
i'll stop
mainly the system is the reason why i
wasn't doing it like that because
you know like i would go to jail and
they're like you know they'll send me to
juvenile hall you know you don't just
get out when you go there
so yeah
i'm sure you make good money
yeah
i do
you have a pimp no
you don't have a pimp no that's got to
be hard for a girl like you on figaro
street without a pimp
yeah cause you're gonna get hassled
by me if you know
if you really know
like it's not hard like to avoid it but
i mean if it's like you know if it's
like there
you know then it is like a little too
much sometimes but
can you imagine what figaro street would
be like if there were no pimps involved
probably be good be out of control
yeah probably it'd probably be better
though it'll be a supermarket of girls
dressed like you mm-hmm
because a lot of girls are afraid to go
out there
yeah
i mean it is dangerous though you know
it's not just a fun it's not a lot of
people make it seem fun
but it's not i mean yeah you can see
your little friends or whatever for a
second but you know they're not really
in your life like that you know just for
a split second
so i'm i wouldn't call that fun
yeah so it's dangerous it's scary most
definitely you know because anything can
happen to you at like any moment
what have you had happened to you
i haven't haven't well i've been robbed
that's like oh and paintball shot
you shot with a paintball yeah great but
that's like the only two things that's
ever happened to me
you carry weapons or defense yes
i mean not really like i don't carry a
gun but
i have all your girls carry guns pepper
spray
you know stuff like that a knife
to protect myself while i'm out there i
mean i wish i could carry again
i mean i can but
i don't i don't know i don't know i'm
not that type of person right
i mean i doesn't mean i want to defend
myself or nothing but
i don't know did you have role models as
a kid
no mom sisters anything like that no if
anything they want to be like me you
know
my family they they really look up to me
now especially
how does this work affect you
emotionally
it's stressful when it's stressful when
it's going bad when it's going good you
know
it's easy to
block the
the nonsense what's a good day look like
for you
like as far as
money well everything but what would be
a good good day in nicole's life
um the only thing that can make it a
good day is money honestly
if i'm not making money then it's not a
good day what's more important do you
love our money
money didn't take you long to answer
that yeah no
because i've been let down and you know
heartbroken and you know i kind of
that's like
locked in
there's like bars around my heart right
now
are you i'm 21. 21.
so at 21 you're looking at your options
in life
you could work at starbucks you could
work it i've had regular jobs
and then you have this
yeah
tell me the difference
the money is faster
and
i don't know i can't work for 25
hours or 22 dollars it never matters 17
an hour i can make 500 in an hour you
know that's the difference for me
yeah that would be hard to go back to
yeah then you end up getting addicted to
it though don't you oh no yeah you
definitely get addicted to this
lifestyle
once you start really making real money
you touch real money it's like you know
you look at somebody else's job and
you're like
you know it couldn't be me
but what what are the prices that you
pay by doing it
you're so you're making more my life in
general is a you know
like
i wouldn't say i like pay a price
because you know
but it probably affects your personal
relationships it did oh yeah it
definitely affects personal relations
the only guy that's going to want to
have a relationship with you and in 99
cases are a pimp
that's not necessarily true because i
mean i mean if the guy outside of that
world
wants to have a relationship with you
he's going to ask you to stop doing what
you're doing
yeah or he respected
because you know you're looking for a
guy a boyfriend who's going to respect
the fact that you're having sex with 10
guys a night i mean i'm not looking for
that you know
i'm not looking for that but i'm not
looking for anything because i can do
this on my own
you know but
you know
are drugs are part of your life no
but um more serious no
good for you
do you call your very first time doing
this at 15 and a half
yeah
tell me about that
um i was super scared the one
i just know i was
standing on the corner
of i think western in first
and um
this guy just wrote up to me but i mean
of course i was like taught to like say
you know specific things or ask for
specific things but i don't know i was
just more so nervous because it was my
first time doing with somebody random
so
um it was awkward
and you know weird until i got the money
and then i was like okay and i it was
fast honestly
you get guys asking you to do stuff
you're not comfortable doing yes every
day how do you handle that
i used to be nice but
since it happened so much i kind of i'd
be a little rude you know
probably might open your car doors or
something what's your favorite kind of
john
i would say
a white man
like christ treat you better yeah
for sure
and asians
do you have dreams of doing something
else with your life of course what do
you want to do
um i want to be a real estate agent
and i want to do a little bit of
cosmetology i'm good at makeup sure you
could do that still yeah of course i
mean that's what i'm working towards you
want to do this for a couple years save
some money and then get out yeah yeah
good for you
where do you stay at night you have like
a motel
no i have an apartment you have your own
apartment yeah
why why do you think it is that most of
the girls that are doing what you do
are just scraping by every day just
trying to pay for a motel room and then
do it again the next day
what do i think about that i mean why do
you think that is
oh cause it's hard out here sometimes
you know not every girl
can you know look the part
money comes easier to you so maybe that
that helps you yeah i mean i've never
had that problem so i don't know
honestly
is going back to a square life
no or is it too boring for you yeah
honestly
it's just once you leave a square life
it's like
you really start seeing things
differently
so
yeah no so you think you're destined to
always live some form of this life i
know
i'm not saying oh well i probably
i wouldn't become a square
but i mean i wouldn't settle down with
someone when i'm like i can't see myself
doing this when i'm 27.
you know i'm ready to have when i want
kids
you know i'm gonna i'm not gonna you
know leave this image for my children
and i'm gonna eventually stop you know
and start my life you know but i just
yeah it's a head start for me kind of
you know
what what do you what have you learned
about men from doing this
a lot
probably bad stuff
cheaters
liars
mainly liars
does that affect the way you
will move forward in a relationship
knowing that these guys are most of them
are like no i wouldn't no it depends
because there's always guys that are
exceptions to that role yeah
yeah but
yeah it really just depends
does it affect your self-esteem
no
doing this
getting all these guys like
no giving you attention
you see through it
what's the best thing that's ever
happened to you out there
the best thing
um
i haven't really had like an enormous
like payday yeah not like it but i know
it will come
um
i think the best thing was
i had a sugar daddy for like two months
that's probably the best thing how much
would he give you
like 2k a day
sometimes 10. 2 000 a day
sometimes 10
sometimes
a dog
5 000 dog you know he's doing a lot for
me how'd you lose him
he trained him
see what i drained him oh you drained
him of his money yeah
yeah
yeah he couldn't control himself yeah he
definitely
he definitely
seen me a lot
you fell in love yeah he did
you know how many times he'll tell me he
loves me
probably like every five minutes
seriously
how do you think working the streets has
changed you
it changed me a lot more aware
um not even just like of the streets but
just
men in general
you know i feel like it just
made me more alert to the world
as far as like what you really what you
really see
and what you really go through because i
you know girls do i remember tons of
stories of what girls go through
you know it just
it scares me even just hearing a story
it's a crazy lifestyle yeah definitely
you don't even have to be on figaro
street or western you could
you could just go i do you can go to a
gas station and
you'll get approached right
yeah weed shop you never know
do you believe you deserve a better life
than this
yes
is it difficult to be around so many
people that are just
you know on the take
everyone everyone's a hustler
the other girls oh it's not even tricks
no
it's not difficult no
i feel like it's a little bit more
easier since everything's like pretty
straightforward
you just know going into it that that's
how people are yeah
do you understand that that's really not
maybe how everyone is what because
you're like a hustler yeah you're in the
hood no i know everybody's not a hustler
it's not meant for everybody yeah but um
but you're down in south central where
everybody's yeah pretty much trust me
but i've been other places
not everybody's a husband i mean there's
girls out here that aren't even real
hustlers you know they pertain to a lot
of people pretend even the guys
they make it they
probably make an image for themselves
and it's really not that in real life
you know
what advice would you give to a girl
who's thinking about doing this
i definitely wouldn't recommend
doing it
like i wouldn't give any like specific
advice because
i don't know this is the lifestyle you
know somebody chooses on their own
i wouldn't necessarily say like oh you
know i wouldn't campaign it
what's your biggest regret
probably
probably a
a pimp
honestly pampers my face getting
involved with it then yeah
it's really not worth it
why does a girl hook up with a pimp is
it just they want the companionship they
want some guy by their side
yeah
and
because they i don't know it's a
manipulation game in my
in my head you know i feel like it's all
sauce
all that stuff that a guy
gives a girl is stuff she can learn on
her own
you know it's not really like they make
it seem like you know we need them
and that's why girls be
stuck trying to get room money you know
that they don't have
like any
motivation or a lot of girls are really
terrible with money yeah so the guy
steps in
your money yeah but then the guys are
terrible with money too so
that's true you know like so it doesn't
even you can't even say like oh
you know it's like but it's a is it a
lonely lifestyle
yeah
yeah
i would say it's real lonely
ironically because you don't really have
anybody like you know you do
unless you have a pimp you don't really
have anybody i mean you can have like a
small little support group you know as
far as you know
immediate family or um like just a
couple friends cause they're not all
your friends you know you might see a
lot of the girls
every day
but
i wouldn't necessarily call them friends
yeah you know just hi
oh you hocialize
yeah let's see girls call it yeah
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
i um say
i would say the streets like working on
the streets is the hardest part
just the gangs yeah
honestly but not all the streets though
i would say like things pray the worst
one of the most dangerous ones like
and it's the most like the most
attention is on facebook
yeah it's a crazy street
there's no nothing you know there's no
other street that compares to it it's a
fashion show
i feel like people get dressed
you know people just get dressed to get
seen and then
you know they're not making no money
like some girls just go out there to
talk or see their friends
yeah it's it's a fashion show it's a
whorehouse it's a
social life it's a it's everything
and you get the guys lined up all
through the night like until five in the
morning right
guy's lying it never stops 20 cars in a
row it never stops who told you five in
the morning no i mean it peeks out oh
yeah no i mean it peeks out it doesn't
slow down at two three four in the
morning
it almost feeds up it's yeah it speeds
up around that time right that's because
because you're picking up the mexican
guys morning traffic everybody's on
their way to work the mexican guys that
go early to work yeah make a stop on
food
not just mexican guys really all guys i
don't know every race
every race be out there
what's your relationship like with your
family now
um i don't talk to my mom but um i have
seven siblings so we talk a lot
not all of us but
a couple of us keep in contact every day
some of us are like you know every
couple days or a week you know
everybody's we still all talk and i know
you're doing this
no no well
my brother knows my dad knows and
uh
my two sisters
is there shame involved in like
maybe towards my family a little bit but
not towards like nobody i don't know
no do you think prostitution should be
legalized yeah yeah
but i don't i don't want to pay taxes so
if that's what they're going to do then
no
you know yeah eventually the price the
prices will be established definitely
that's probably not good
that's gonna mess up everything
what would you say nicole is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
i would say the most important lesson is
to not just don't just trust anybody
because
you could i mean you could get yourself
in
a lot of situations just by putting just
a little bit of trust into somebody you
know
you can't trust nobody here
yeah all right i mean i've learned a lot
of lessons but i feel like the trust one
is probably the biggest one
it's all on you
it's you against everyone else exactly
all right nicole thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah no problem be
careful out there
thank you
you